[Musique]
non
bonjour et bienvenue dans si on sortait
la nouvelle émission de tv 78
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la maison elsa
triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et nous sommes
avec guillaume roubaud kwasi le
directeur bonjour bonjour alors jusqu'au
29 novembre ou incident celui il ya une
exposition consacrée aux couples
d'artistes bernard prat et à nakache
pourquoi avoir fait cette exposition
alors c'est vrai que cette maison la
maison à la triolet louis aragon nous
avons l'habitude depuis l'ouverture en
1994 d'organiser des expositions
d'artistes contemporains part cela nous
continuons l'esprit et les démarches
d'aragon les attribue au lait qui eux
mêmes étaient liés aux milieux
artistiques et entretenir avec eux des
liens étroits donc nous poursuivons 7,7
c'est cette dimension là et puis
l'intérêt aussi avec bernard prat et à
nakache c'est bien sûr l'intérêt de
l'horreur mais il y avait en plus un
petit clin d'oeil puisque cette maison
d'un couple d'écrire et là en
l'occurrence bien que le nom l indique
pas non plus et bien après la cache sont
à la ville un couple par ailleurs un
couple de créateurs et donc il ya deux
lieux trois lieux mêmes d'exposition sur
bernard est un pur à nakache bernard
prat il utilise des objets désuets et
qu'on n'utilise plus pour créer
qu'est ce qui te voir comme oeuvre
remarquable alors c'est vrai que c'est
une vraie interrogation sur le regard à
skis et deux opérés par bernard prat
dans le sens où vous pouvez avoir des
objets très noble des grands tableaux de
la peinture 10 ont explosé dans les
grands musées je pense par exemple aux
joueurs de fifres de manet et là en
l'occurrence il va décomposé ou
recomposées si on veut le joueur de
fifre de monnaie en passant de deux
dimensions à trois dimensions
et puis en utilisant effectivement des
objets du objets du quotidien ou des
objets
auquel on associe pas si vous voulez la
belle et la hotte peinture dont vous
pouvez avoir un extincteur ou des zones
en plastique des choses tout à fait de
récupération donc ça c'était évidemment
une réflexion sur les deux dimensions
les trois dimensions sur les points de
vue sur le noble sur ce qui n'est pas
noble
ça nous permet d'avoir un autre regard
sur un tassement brodeur qui peuvent
exister par ailleurs est ce qu'il ya
aussi un côté un peu engagés je pensais
à l'oeuvre d'être retard où on peut voir
aussi beaucoup d'objets qui pourraient
être dans la mer est ce qu'il ya un côté
engagé de sa part alors c'est vrai que
quand on me demande quand on lui demande
de se définir en un mot c'est la
dimension ludique sur laquelle il
insisté c'est vrai qu'il ya évidemment
une part de jeu
dans toutes ces recompositions cependant
c'est vrai qu'il ya à travers ce
derrière le jeu il ya aussi des
réflexions sur l'art est aussi de
réflexion sur le visible et de réflexion
aussi au delà c'est sur ce que vous
dites jeu par rapport à la falaise aux
falaises d'étretat qui est une oeuvre
importante qu'on explose ici c'est très
bien sûr que ça ça fait c'est aussi pour
nous pour nous réveiller au pour nous
mettre en éveil disons par rapport aux
questions de la pollution évidemment
c'est vrai à nakache elle elle dit elle
allie à la fois le tricot la couture la
photographie et elle traite un peu du
féminin de la femme
comment elle fait pour lier un petit peu
les deux alors c'est vrai que c'est un
jeu avec les attendus disons la femme
elle tricote el kouhen étant le linge
bon donc des choses
des enfants donc c'est à dire des choses
très traditionnelle est convenu est en
fait là elle va proposer un un regard
nouveau sur ces choses là un peu décalé
c'est à dire que oui elle étend le linge
mais vous allez voir que le linge en
l'occurrence puis en lieu de pendre il
s'élève par exemple l'un des enfants ou
alors quand il s'agit de de couture ou
de tricot parfois il faut reconnaître
que les choses qui sont tricotés ou qui
sont prévues ne relève pas forcément du
modèle delà de la bonne ménagère ou de
la femme rangée
donc il ya évidemment une grande liberté
si vous voulez dans une manière de
revoir de regarder de retraverser les
attendus sur ce que c'est qu'être une
femme là il ya un regard très libre sur
la féminité au 21e siècle et donc c'est
un couple d'artistes comment ils se
complètent dans l'exposition
alors c'est vrai que chacun a vraiment
sa personnalité on peut on peut vraiment
pas dire que l'un copie l'autre ou l'un
serait l'élève de l'autre cependant
c'est vrai qu'il ya des quelques
éléments qui peuvent être qu'ils peuvent
se penser ensemble il ya un voeu sur les
deux dimensions les trois dimensions
dans les deux cas et a même un jeu sur
les épingles je sais pas si vous avez vu
sur l'oeuvre qui est un christ à loudun
on a aussi des parties du visage du
christ qui était pas en l'occurrence
suspendu par des épingles cure défilent
des choses comme ça mais dans les deux
cas pour aller au delà de cette
dimension presque anecdotique c'est vrai
qu'il ya un regard sur le sur mesure ce
qui est sûr sur les attentes du cidre
est quelque chose de ludique on retrouve
un peu dans les deux cas c'est vrai de
décaler de 7,7 c'est assez clair et vous
personnellement quel est votre coup de
coeur qu'ils soient du côté de la cage
de bernard prat alors c'est vrai que le
joueur de ce chiffre est
particulièrement impressionnant plus
c'est une oeuvre qu'il faut bien
imaginez fait plus de 5 mètres de
longueur 9 très impressionnante et je
crois que celle que je préfère malgré
tout dans ce que nous explosons c'est le
des cartes des cardiaques vador je
trouve assez assez fascinant parce que
il nous interroge aussi sur ce que c'est
qu'être un homme libre c'est quand même
une des grandes pensées de descartes la
liberté qui est presque définitoire de
l'homme et ceux des cartes il est fait
beaucoup avec des dark vador qui
reviennent à plusieurs reprises dans ce
personnage un peu ambivalent
anakin skywalker le truc c'est plutôt
intéressant comme comme perspective par
ailleurs même s'il ya un choc un peu des
temporalités et des continents pour ceux
qui ne peuvent pas le voir en fait donc
c'est un des cartes qu'on peut voir à
travers un carré vous pouvez si vous
voulez les oeuvres de bernard prat sont
là en l'occurrence dans ces deux cas
précis le joueur de fifre roule ou le
des cartes sont des tableaux qui sont
bien connus en deux dimensions
et là il valait il va les faire en trois
dimensions donc dans l'espace et
simplement en vous plaçant à un endroit
précis et bien les différents éléments
constitutifs qui sont deux éléments de
la vie de tous les jours quotidienne et
bien vont reformer dans avec votre oeil
si vous voulez la toile en deux
dimensions et donc mais vous invite
parce que vous avez vu la composition si
vous voulez cette toile vous invite à la
pensée un petit peu différemment
formidable c'est vraiment une chouette
exposition est à voir
oui je crois à découvrir jusqu'à la fin
du mois de novembre c'est tous les jours
à partir de 14 heures jusqu'à 18h très
bien merci à guy poubeau kwasi vous en
prie merci à vous merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission on se retrouve bientôt
pour de nouvelles idées de sorties dans
les yvelines
[Musique]